time for what's trending las vegas snow
host mercedes martinez joining us from
the mix 94.1
studio hi mercedes good morning hi
mercedes good morning good morning happy
friday you guys we've got some great
stuff trending this morning the biebs is
trending this morning
he just announced that his clothing
brand drew house
is teaming up with crocs now
i've never been a huge fan of crocs but
these are so cute they're lavender with
little rabbits teddy bears
and other characters from bieber's brand
but wait
there's more there the crocs also come
with a pair of drew house socks because
justin bieber says crocs with socks is
definitely
the move you can actually get your feet
on these crocs
on tuesday next up watch out
netflix is trying to hit the stop button
on
password sharing users will get messages
that prompt them to create their own
account if they don't live with the
owner of the account they're using
so to continue watching netflix will
make you verify the account
with the code sent to the email or phone
of the main person
netflix has different tiers that allow
customers to add up to four
devices so it could be some trouble if
you're sharing that password alex
yeah gonna be asking for a lot of codes
all right so easter mercedes is about
three weeks away i can't believe it
i've seen the cadbury eggs in the stores
but it's also crunch time for their
animals too
yeah the top ten finalists for the years
cadbury bunny
were just announced and check this out
look how cute they are
there are dogs a mini horse an alpaca a
frog
and of course a bunny with the best
bunny name ever
potato i just love that you can vote on
your favorite one to help decide which
gets to wear the coveted bunny ears
and star in this year's easter
commercials and you can actually vote on
cadbury's website
so who's your vote for alex uh well i
love
dogs so the dog gets my vote here's your
vote
i think i go for the alpaca just to
change it up a little bit
i love when animals are named after food
too like waffles eggo
that's my next dog
all right mercedes it's great to see you
have a wonderful weekend
have a wonderful weekend thanks guys you
too